I've been reading your books which are
so beautifully written thank you where
did you tap into what did you tap into
to write the children's books the way
that you write them and there's a board
book and a there's one for girls and one
for boys and two different ages you're
such a good writer you're so nice thank
you so much um that's what my mom tells
me I'm like still not feeling like I'm a
writer but I do really enjoy writing but
it's such a vulnerable place nothing
more vulnerable than writing why is that
it's like being nak and it's hard to sit
down and like tap
into like get into the zone to do it
like especially deep in motherhood I'm
like oh finding the time to write feels
like a
selfish Everything feels selfish when
kids I know I know um but like I have to
go to the bathroom before drop off yeah
oh no they're all in there why do you
want to be in here right now I don't
understand
like my I mean my girls are in
everything same okay good that makes me
feel so much better same um wait we were
going so you to block out time oh yeah
to carve out that time did you do it in
an organized fashion did it just hit you
when like a a a sentence would flow so
when I wrote my first children's book it
was from my daughter and um it was when
I was going back to work and she was
like severely colic and she only liked
me
and I was just like called back to work
which I was really excited about but
just scared and I remember that feeling
of just being like okay I feel like
she's being I don't know our bond is
just changing instantly and like a set
is no place for a child so I would like
try to make that work and force the
nanny to come and then she'd be stuck in
an hour traffic and the like it was just
not working out so it was like a messy
time and I remember just getting home at
like midnight and feeling like I
shouldn't wake her up but like I just
needed to hold her and then I just just
started thinking about how Brave she was
having to be being away from me and I
just wrote out a bunch of stuff on on
the notes of my phone and it was born
like that so I woke I went into my
husband's room and I was like or sorry
not his room our room and I'm like I
think we sleep separately we have
different floors and I'm like I think I
wrote a children's book and he's like
what how cool is that yeah yeah it was
pretty cool it's so good and then you
have one for is it Luca but it is still
for a smaller child so Luca's book came
later he was obviously pissed he's like
what the hell why does my sister have a
book I came first I did all the things
first they all get to look to me and so
this book is for younger boys but it was
the most lovely trip down memory lane to
think about all that he taught me and
all that I wanted to teach him and like
I just love him so much and he is the
experience was so different with him as
my first and only child and being a boy
than with my girls so um it was really
just like a love letter to him and
appreciating how sweet and kind he was
and thinking about how the dialogue has
changed a lot in our society and how we
need to
respect um boys and all the things that
they come along with and not just be
like be tough be strong you're okay I
like in the book how there's a a like a
one page about how when something feels
wrong like pay attention to that but
then the next page is like and when
something feels right like lean into
that and be brave about it I mean I just
I love your books they're really amazing
and um I just want to let everybody know
that everyone in the audience is going
to go home with a copy of your beautiful
book my little sweet boy and my little
Brave
[Music]
girl